[Musique]
e
j'ai commencé à dessin sur papier et
c'était compliqué au début parce qu'il
fallait acheter du matériel se forme et
c'était très compliqué ce qui a fait que
avec le temps et avec l'arrivée
d'internet au cameroun l'arrivée dès
réseaux sociaux je ne suis rendu compte
de l'opportunité de se former sous forme
est soi-même chercher des tutoriels en y
aller surtout faire c'est les vidéos de
formation et c'est donc petit à petit
ainsi que je me suis retrouvé dans l'art
numérique
[Musique]
outils traditionnels sont plus coûteux
sont plutôt court comparé à ce qu'on
peut faire avec la numérique parce que
bon quand tu réfléchis à allaiter leur
que tu dois acheter des formats les big
les pinceaux et doux tout ça est déjà
disponible dans le logiciel que vous
utilisez dans dans l'ordinateur et ça
rend les choses vraiment passé
[Musique]
nous sommes en retard nous avons
énormément de retard technique surtout
humains pour réaliser des oeuvres parce
que le le le le défi c'est que je veux
dire quoi le spectateur africain
paradoxe à main aussi exigeant que si
vous étiez hollywood si vous faites des
dessins animés des bandes dessinées donc
il ya ce challenge là d'arriver à
rattraper l'énorme retard pour produire
quelque chose de qualité mais de signer
localement
[Musique]